et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui max
et mot du journal Le Monde bonjour Marc
bonjour et Gautier rivinsky la rédaction
de France 24 bonjour Gauthier la liberté
pour Britney grinder après bientôt 10
mois d'incarcération en Russie la basket
aux Américaines et de retour chez elle
et les États-Unis ont obtenu sa
libération à l'échange de celle d'un
trafiquant d'armes Victor Booth relâché
vers la Russie écouter Joe Biden
elle est en sécurité elle est à bord
d'un avion et elle est en route vers les
États-Unis après avoir été retenu
prisonnière pendant plusieurs mois en
Russie dans des conditions intolérables
Britney sera bientôt de retour dans les
bras de ses proches là où elle aurait dû
se trouver pendant tout ce temps
dans le cas de Britney Hitler une
décision partielle de la justice russe
une justice qui est partielle n'est plus
une justice alors effectivement ce qui
est ce qui est arrivé à cette
basketteuse qui est connue puisqu'elle a
été si je ne m'abuse médaillée au
lindouble médaillé olympique et donc
effectivement elle a été arrêtée à l'un
des aéroports de Moscou en possession
d'une dose donc destinée à la vapoteuse
où il y avait du cannabis à vertu ou à
fonction thérapeutique elle avait une
prescription pour cela évidemment ça
n'est pas passé auprès de la justice
russe et d'autant plus ou d'autant moins
que effectivement elle est militante de
la cause homosexuelle elle-même
revendiquait assumer et sans problème
apparent et ça ça n'est pas possible
pour les Russes alors d'ailleurs il faut
revenir à cette expression qui est
employée par les Russes par la justice
Rue c'est par Poutine la propagande
homosexuelle ce qui prouve bien en
arrière-plan l'ignorance ou la volonté
d'être ignorant comme si l'homosexualité
quelque chose qu'on attrapait comme une
communauté une grippe ou au contraire
comme un contact bienfaisant c'est
absolument débile il faut bien le dire
ou une cause politique ou une cause
politique que l'on embrasse évidemment
mais là c'est plutôt la promotion tout à
fait naturelle des droits des
homosexuels et ça ça n'est pas passé
effectivement qui a eu un effet
d'obéenne pour la justice pour le
pouvoir russe en disant on engrange
justement des cartouches pardonnez-moi
de le dire comme ça mais c'est
probablement de la sorte que on
considère ce type de détention oui sans
doute mais ça n'était pas si vous voulez
au départ quelque chose qui était
simplement du enfin prévu pour un
marchandage tel quel mais qui était la
manière aussi de montrer comment on
débusqué en Russie ce type de personnage
considéré comme profondément des
cadences une arrestation interview
quelques jours seulement avant le
déclenchement de l'invasion russe de
l'Ukraine c'est un peu prémédité Marc
Seymour volonté délibérée d'en faire le
cas échéant ou le moment venu un
instrument de négociation oui
alors là on s'est retrouvé dans une
scène qui est assez étonnante alors les
lieux ont changé c'est plus le pont des
espions et là je suis prêt c'est à Abu
Dhabi justement c'était l'image de cette
de la nouvelle donne aujourd'hui mais on
est dans la même logique qui est celle
de marchandage des changes et c'est
extrêmement significatif c'est-à-dire
malgré la avec la guerre malgré la
guerre des contacts existent et
là-dessus la démarche des américains est
totalement différente de celle
d'Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron dit moi je veux parler à
Poutine je vais essayer de convaincre
Poutine il espère que son charme et la
raison fera un effet sur Poutine je
baded Dinan moi je ne veux pas par la
poutine tant je ne veux pas lui parler
au téléphone tant qu'il n'a rien à
proposer de concret pour dénégociations
mais en même temps l'administration
américaine parle tous azimut pour
obtenir les libération de la basketteuse
pour aussi le cas il est toujours bloqué
de Paul woman qui est un ancien marine
accusé des cocons d’années pour
espionnage mais même au-delà
c'est-à-dire le chef de
a été rencontré ces homologues frustrant
Turquie d'ailleurs
pour faire passer le message que s'il y
avait un emploi de l'arme nucléaire mais
tactique ou même simplement de la bombe
sale c'est-à-dire des obus qui tombaient
sur un dépôt de matière radioactive
catastrophe les Amériques il sera
auraient des conséquences immenses donc
voilà il y a un contact et
c'est un peu à la fois rassurant parce
que bon
et en même temps c'est quand même le
début d'une logique qui rentre dans
celle d'une guerre longue alors bon pour
les Russes c'était une manière de faire
un geste
probablement mais en même temps Poutine
comme il sait très bien de faire sauf le
chaud et le froid il dit c'est une
guerre qui va encore durer longtemps il
a dit là en recevant devant la son
espèce de Conseil des droits de l'homme
qui est une institution à la mode du
Kremlin voilà on
s'installe dans la guerre il y a une
logique comme le dit à Marx est mot
différent de celle dans Emmanuel Macron
qui si on écoute Marc un serait
peut-être tenté davantage d'amadouer de
jouer finalement sur la fibre
humaine ou sentimentale de Vladimir
Poutine une logique finalement beaucoup
plus de container ou de Réal politique
qui consisterait pour les Américains à
être purement et simplement dans du
marchandage d'ailleurs ils l'ont précisé
ces discussions donc concernées que le
sort des Américains détenus aussi
aucunement un éventuel des jeunes entre
les deux pays au point important de la
part de Washington oui c'est une mise au
point important d'autant plus importante
que justement elle tente de cacher
désespérément ce qui doit être caché aux
yeux de Washington c'est à dire que ce
que disait Marc est tout à fait juste il
y a des contacts non seulement certains
ont été repris mais certains n'ont
jamais disparu mais pourquoi les
publie-t-on en quelque sorte pourquoi
les grands ton public parce que ils sont
très lentement même si ça doit être très
lent une forme de délitimation du combat
de l'Ukraine et du combat contre le le
la machine totalitaire ou
potentiellement totalitaire de Poutine
c'est ça qu'on est en train de voir veut
pas dire quelque chose où l'on dirait
regardez quand même quand on arrive à
parler quand on arrive à libérer la
basketteuse c'est pas si mal on est sur
le bon chemin on devrait reprendre
langue avec Poutine j'entendais
récemment quand même sur notre antenne
des anciens diplomates dire l'essentiel
c'est de renouer le commerce le business
avec Poutine alors que pendant 22 ans
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait d'autre rien que
ça on a vu à quoi ça ça a donné on se
souvient de ce qu'a dit le président
allemand Steiner qui a dit nous nous
sommes trompés parce que nous avons cru
justement qu'à force de contact basé sur
la rationalité du commerce du marché on
arrivera à quelque chose mais non on
entend encore cette rengaine et y
compris de la part des Américains qui
disent non on ne touche pas la situation
politique on ne se on méprise les Russes
de ce point de vue là mais on parle avec
eux et qui est encore une fois un
contact il a toujours existé même au
niveau des militaires simplement que
l'on publie avec autant de ramdam de
tambour cette annonce fait que on est en
train de me semble-t-il d'initier
quelque chose qui viserait à dire de la
direction
ukrainienne et par-delà au combat
qu'elle mène écoutez ça suffit
maintenant on a suffisamment donné on a
suffisamment tergiverser pour vous
soutenir maintenant on arrête et on
commence à parler
Ukraine conflit annexe les Russes sont
trop importants pour devenir un
fréquentable non d'abord il y a cette
réalité la Russie est là elle restera là
où elle est importante immense bon donc
d'une manière ou d'une autre faudra
faire avec la Russie mais je pense que
la question aujourd'hui d'un point de
vue américain français d'ailleurs est un
peu différente c'est-à-dire
il y a de la part des Américains un
message de moins en moins subliminal
qu'ils font passer j'avais été notamment
les diverses déclarations du chef
d'état-major Mark Miley qui dit bon la
guerre est un gagnable pour les
ukrainiens et il y a peut-être un
créneau dans lequel on pourrait imaginer
de négocier ensuite il y a eu des pas
dans l'escalade très fort des Ukrainiens
qui ont été c'est drone envoyé sur des
bases distantes de 600 700 km à
l'intérieur des frontières russières du
côté de sarathov de cours
le troisième donc Elisa américains ont
dit ouvertement qu'il n'approuvaient pas
ça donc il y a cette peur du moment où
d'une manière ou d'une autre il voudront
essayer d'enrayer l'escalade et que les
Ukrainiens qui ont pour eux
effectivement le droit qui ont pour eux
la légitimité aussi de la morale et des
souffrances subies dit non nous on veut
aller jusqu'au bout on veut récupérer
ton territoire y compris la Crimée mais
on sait que si on va jusque là ça sera
une escalade assez redoutable et donc je
pense qu'il y a déjà de la part
des Américains cette volonté un peu de
rappeler qui est en réalité c'est aussi
ce qui a fait très maladroitement notre
président dire la question centrale la
question se fera celle des garanties de
sécurité pour la Russie en partie c'est
vrai mais c'est peut-être pas la
question prioritaire et surtout ça ne se
dit pas comme ça
dans ce moment mais on est quand même
dans un moment où je pense qu'il y a une
volonté de faire passer ce signal aux
Ukrainiens on est déjà un peu dans
l'après et oui c'est ça que disent
finalement cet échange de prisonnier
tout à fait mais en passant par
bertheuset profit non seulement ce que
défend vous avez dit le droit la morale
tout à fait mais ce que nous nous avons
à défendre dans cette affaire là et ça
c'est terminé on en parle plus
c'est-à-dire le fait que il y est un
combat presque élémentaire et basique
contre ce que représente Poutine mais ce
que pourrait représenter d'autres mais
au nom de l'Ukraine il lui fallut
renoncer à négocier la libération de
brittengriner non avec les Russes pas
forcément mais ne pas lui donner une
telle publicité on aurait pu apprendre
effectivement qu'ils avaient été libérés
d'autant que le personnage russe qui lui
profite justement est un est un olibrius
de première parlons justement de Victor
boot ce trafiquant d'armes à qui sait
toujours lui déclaré innocent des
accusations pour lesquelles les
États-Unis n'ont tout de même condamné à
25 ans derrière les barreaux il aurait
pourtant contourner des embargos sur sur
plusieurs pays de de livraison d'armes
max c'est bon oui enfin je me suis pas
spécialement plongé de dedans
debout mais c'est effectivement un de
ces grands graphismes
prospérés à l'ombre de
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique on
voit c'est une confirmation à quel point
il était qu'elle est profondément liée
structures de force et c'est si le
Vikings comme on les appelle qui sont
les hommes qui ont toujours Poutine et
qui ont toujours été
et qui tenait des manettes et voilà et
ça fait longtemps que les Russes
faisaient des pressions de diverses
manières pour obtenir un échange un
profiteur de guerre finalement comme il
en existe beaucoup dans l'environnement
des conflits armés alors bien sûr les
Russes on cite régulièrement et gagner
Prigogine par exemple le même proche de
Vladimir Poutine avec le groupe Wagner
enfin les Américains aussi ils ont black
hauteur il y a des acteurs privés dans
les guerres et Victor boot n'est pas le
seul tout à fait simplement là je
rejoins ce que disait Marc à l'instant
il y a une extrême porosité entre les
milieux justement barbouzes on va dire
ou de la pègre d'ailleurs quelqu'un
avait relevé le langage les mots les
occurrences ver et sémantique d'un
Poutine ou même d'un maître fédé qui
sont en accord avec ces milieux là et là
il y a une extrême proximité je dis pas
que Blackwater ça dit rien c'est tout à
fait quelque chose de d'important
malheureusement mais là vous avez
vraiment une une sorte pas de
juxtaposition mais de coexistence avec
beaucoup de contacts entre les qui sont
effectivement les représentants les
forces de l'ordre aux en général et ce
type de de personnages qui d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit en profiter de
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique en
récupérant des matériels de guerre et
ensuite en les revendant
systématiquement quasi systématiquement
à des gens qui étaient des fauteurs de
guerre notamment en Afrique et je pense
à Charles Stella au Liberia si ce n'est
que oui bon si tant que oui et sans
aucun immortalité qui est une société
qui a pignon sur eux ils vont c'est pas
très bien mais voilà mais ça comme
Wagner jusqu'à il y a très peu de temps
le réduisait Wagner mais non qu'est-ce
que c'est on ne connaît pas privilégié
il faisait des procès à tous ceux qui
disaient qu'il était le chef de Wagner
tout donc on on est même dans un monde
très glauque et très opaque autre sujet
c'est devenu lui un acteur de la guerre
presque malgré lui de la guerre en
Ukraine ce jeudi Olaf Scholl célèbre sa
première année à la Chancellerie à la
tête d'une coalition hétéroclite de
verre de socio-démocrates et de libero
il assure réarmer l'Allemagne et fournir
un même des armements à l'Ukraine c'est
ça la grande nouveauté sous sa direction
marque ces mots oui alors ça a été sa
grande annonce voilà l'Allemagne prend
conscience des choses on va donner 100
milliards pour s'ammer alors ensuite une
grande partie de cet argent est passé à
commander du matériel américain il y a
une logique parce que c'est du matériel
qui est prêt que ce soit pour les F35 en
heure la livrée des patriotes à la
Pologne par exemple
etc mais et ensuite j'avais beaucoup
c'est plus compliqué d'arriver à une
vraie culture de la guerre au de la
défense et de la guerre il faudra
beaucoup de temps à l'Allemagne mais oui
c'est une coalition alors en plus c'est
la première fois que c'est une coalition
à trois
qu'il dirige parce que jusqu'ici dans
toute l'histoire de l'Allemagne de la
prière il y avait une seule fois un
gouvernement tout seul de la Cedeo dans
les années 50 dans 57 je crois ensuite
c'est toujours été des coalition à deux
là pour la première fois il y a une
coalition à trois et c'est quand même
très très moyennement convaincant donc
le moment est historique pour
l'Allemagne les trois piliers du modèle
allemand qui était
l'énergie pas cher grâce au gaz russe
qui était les exportations à fond
notamment grâce à la Chine et la
sécurité grâce aux Américains ce sont
effondrés donc c'est un moment
historique et c'est difficile pour
l'Allemagne et on a le sentiment que ni
la coalition qui est sans arrêt
tirailler et ni à fortiorer la chose
mais à la hauteur Olympus c'est pas il
est pas très charismatique il est même
Fallot oui falot pour jouer oui
il n'a pas apparemment d'humour alors
peut-être dans le privé mais on sait pas
mais Angela Merkel au moins dans le
privilège avait beaucoup et puis en gala
Merkel avait quand même eu un certain
nombre d'intuitions donc on est quand
même dans un moment où
l'histoire revient dans ce qu'elles
peuvent avoir de plus tragique on voit
même l'extrême droite qui remonte en
Allemagne comme témoin de la prestation
là de ce groupe uscules qui qui
préparait des décodage un coup d'État
mais des complots et on a un chancelier
qui a disons
peut-être pas à l'envergure l'envergure
en tout cas il est critiqué alors il a
peut-être pas l'envergure mais il a des
projets qui qui font jaser on peut dire
en Europe critiquer pour faire cavalier
seul par la France notamment est-ce
qu'on a raison Gauthier
alors partiellement oui c'est à dire que
dans l'heure
dans la foulée de dans le siège de ce
que vient de dire Marc il y a
effectivement cette façon qui a eu
l'Allemagne à la fois pour des raisons
vertueuses et pour des raisons peut-être
simplement d'intérêt personnel entre
guillemets de se placer justement sous
divers parapluies militaires chez les
Américains tu l'as dit c'était
l'Europe la Chine pour le commerce et la
Russie pour l'énergie et quand tout ça
recule il faut bien trouver des
substituts et ces substitut c'est
effectivement ce qui est très curieux
dans une coalition où l'un des hommes
forts de cette coalition s'appelle
Christiane Léna chef des libéraux comme
on peut difficilement l'être plus et qui
admet que l'État mette 200 milliards
d'euros sur la table pour dire on va
sauver effectivement l'industrie on va
sauver le tissu économique allemand et
il y a encore une fois un grand écart de
l'Allemagne entre ce qu'elle est par
exemple en termes de justement se filer
social que peut représenter l'état et
les exigences de l'un des membres de la
coalition de la même manière que le
grand écart allemand et c'est pour ça
que je voudrais en venir là a été aussi
de refuser systématiquement de devenir
un grand diplomatique ou un grand pays
militaire en version en vertu bien sûr
de du passé mais aussi parce que c'était
commode et que de se mettre sous ses
différents parapluies c'était
extrêmement commode et là aujourd'hui
patatras on lui demande aussi de prendre
position sur le militaire d'un mot ce
qu'il faut quand même souligner c'est
que ce sont les vers aujourd'hui avec un
aller-neberbock et avec qui est le
ministre de l'économie qui sont pour une
participation directe de l'armée
allemande et rappelons quand même qu'il
y a eu un précédent qui était très
intéressant c'était en 98,99 Yoshka
Fisher ancien gauchiste et que la presse
de droite émet à représenté avec un pavé
à lancer dans les années 70 sur les
policiers et qui disait mais l'armée
allemande peut intervenir dans des
causes justes et nobles et c'est ce qui
s'est passé au Kosovo seulement après
l'Afghanistan a fait que les Allemands
sur cette position de l'armée on reflué
mais aujourd'hui effectivement la
question s'est posée se repose et là de
manière déchirante précisément parce que
ces soutiens ces échafaudages qui
éteignez la position allemande ce sont
effondrés en plus sur la question
justement des interventions là-dessus
les verres ont été en pointe parce que
bon le slogan c'était ni leader cree que
j'avais plus de guerre
ce que dit jusqu'à Fischer à cette
époque là c'était jamais plus
d'Auschwitz exactement et à partir de là
c'est le c'est le fil qui explique
l'évolution allemande depuis et là
l'Ukraine c'était un cas flagrant mais
les libéraux ont toujours été
contre toute chose qui ne soit pas une
diplomatie des affaires parce qu'ils
n'ont
jamais marqué le moins de véritables
intérêts ni sur les interventions ni
sur autre chose et les socio-démocrates
ont été quand même plus qu'ambigu on l'a
vu encore avec cette meilleure comme
l'acteur président avec la Russie
c'était quand même eux on a vu surtout
Gerard qui finalement a été formations
et tout mais qui a été le la caricature
de cette espèce d'osmose avec la Russie
donc on est effectivement dans ce
paradoxe où les vers sont les seuls à
porter ce drapeau juste
l'attitude de l'Allemagne aussi il faut
jamais l'oublier ça va changer avec les
générations mais est aussi dû à cette la
culpabilité vis-à-vis du monde slave et
c'est pas une excuse mais ça veut dire
aussi que quand on considère qu'on ne
peut pas aller trop loin avec les Russes
c'est parce qu'on se souvient de ce que
le nazisme a causé justement aux Russes
ou cela au Polonais etc merci Gauthier
merci également à Marc et d'avoir été
avec nous non on va plus loin prochain
journal dans 3 minutes sur France 24